president guillermolasso had bet on
Sunday's constitutional referendum and
local elections to turn around as
political fortunes
El Domingo what happened on Sunday was a
call from the people to the government
and we are not going to evade that
responsibility but it was also to the
entire political leadership and the
state
Ecuadorian people have asked us they
have asked all the parties and groups to
stop fighting amongst ourselves and to
get to work to solve the Urgent and
concrete problems of our people
instead a majority of ecuadorians turned
their back on him
an election day voters said they were
divided on the eight questions of the
referendum that lasso said was Paramount
to address the country's current
political and security crisis
some voters believed him I've voted yes
because I believe that these reforms are
necessary for the country we are still a
democracy in construction
but most perceive the referendum as
little more than a way for lasso to try
to regain initiative after proving
unable to pass any reforms through a
hostile Congress
lasso already had more than enough time
to try and help the country but he
failed there are no jobs and no help for
the Youth we feel helpless there is so
much crime and we can't live in peace
anymore
the referendum also called for the
extradition of citizens linked to
organize crime
and the rising violence also crept into
the election campaign to left this
mayoral candidates were killed before
the polls opened some had to vote under
extreme security measures something
Ecuador had never witnessed before
in the end the real winner of the night
was former leftist president Rafael
Correa he received the results in Mexico
surrounded by his allies candidates of
his party took back the mayorality of
the capital Quito and for the first time
in 30 years that of the country's
largest city by a Kill
Korea lives in Exile in Belgium he was
sentenced in absentia to eight years in
prison in 2020 and controversial bribery
allegations
the right lost across the board at
National level the conservative social
party in particular is left with very
few provinces while we see the left and
in particular Progressive movements like
careers and the indigenous party Rising
it leaves the government in a much more
unfavorable scenario
the last leaves lasso with little to no
space to maneuver he already barely
survived an impeachment vote back in
June following weeks of protests that
rocked the country and raising doubts
now that he will be able to remain in
office for the two years left in his
administration Alessandro al-jaziraquito